hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
in case you haven't already seen there
are some videos floating around that
suggest that the iPhone six-plus bends a
lot my buddy Lou from unbox therapy
uploaded a video yesterday you've
probably already seen it and it's
clearly demonstrating in his video that
he's bending his iphone six-plus
with his bare hands and thus bendgate
was born so here's what you need to know
about what's going on here first there
were a few articles of people putting
this huge iphone in their front pocket
and then noticing some little bends
after a while or after some activity and
then some articles were published about
how this may be a problem and then Lou's
video was published which blew up but of
course in Lou's demo he's actually
trying to bend the phone he's putting a
lot of force into it for a prolonged
period of time much more than these
phones are designed to handle on an
everyday basis and basically pulls on it
until it compromises the structural
integrity of the body of the phone now
we have a large surface like that
especially a soft metal like aluminum
the center of it tends to be the weakest
point and that's where it's going to
bend but imagine you have a piece of
paper and you fold it in half a couple
of times you can continue to fold it in
half and bend it as much as you want but
eventually you'll get to a point where
the paper is so thick that you can't
quite fold it in half one more time
that's because at that point the paper
is now thicker it's now reinforced by
the other pieces of paper and now it's
also much more compact the iPhone 6 is
back is not compact it's not reinforced
and it's not thick it's a large flat
thin sheet of unibody aluminum so of
course when you twist it or torque it or
put a lot of pressure into it it's going
to give because that's what soft metals
do so why make a phone apple out of a
material that's going to easily Bend
when you twist it well obviously number
one like we said those are not normal
forces it's supposed to be taking but
also number two why don't other metal
phones Bend like that we have the HTC
One m8 you try to bend that thing it
absolutely will not Bend even a little
bit and even other phones that have a
bit of metal around the outside like the
Moto X 2014 that didn't really Bend
either when I tried as it turns out most
of these other smart phones have what's
called a magnesium chassis and magnesium
makes up the chassis inside of these
other phones the iPhone 6 does
have that and unfortunately that's why
it's not quite a structurally sound also
it's a large flat sheet of aluminum
which means it has plenty of stress
points where it could easily Bend where
a lot of these other phones are made of
multiple parts where if you try to bend
it you're not really bending a very
large sheet you're bending a more
compact part of the back of the phone
which isn't going to bend the whole
thing for the record though the iPhone 6
is not the only phone to bend the iPhone
5s the Samsung Galaxy s4
the Sony Xperia z1 the iPhone 5 the Oppo
find five these are all bent phones
noted to bend under high amounts of
pressure but then again its high amounts
of pressure just avoid high amounts of
pressure but since it's a bit more of an
expensive Apple product that happens to
be known for its design and its build
quality and material use over the years
it's going to get a lot more attention
because you would expect this to hold up
better than others now the thing is it
might seem like a big deal now bendgate
who's trending worldwide on pretty much
every social network out there but it's
only a couple phones that are actually
bending like this you may or may not
recall Apple has sold 10 million iPhone
6s and 6 pluses this past weekend so a
couple of phones bending will not cause
a recall in fact they can just replace a
couple of them at the Apple store and
that's much quieter and much less
expensive if you have an iPhone 6 and
you're worried about bending your pocket
first of all don't be worried unless
you're like extreme sitting
or doing some other weird things in your
pants but there's a new Tod today video
up and I'll leave a link to that video
right below the like button I'll also
leave loose video but the TLD video
shows that having a case on your iPhone
6 plus may actually help with the
structural rigidity
again it's an already massive phone and
putting a case on that already huge
phone will make it even bigger but if
you're that concerned about putting it
in your back pocket or front pocket and
bending it then that's an option you
have but it all comes down to for me is
and I've said this before the iPhone 6
plus is 6.9 millimeters thin it's a
super thin phone but because of that you
have a protruding camera you have a
slightly smaller than it could be
battery and you now have it bending and
I think if they made a slightly thicker
iPhone six-plus you would not only not
have a
in camera but you'd also have a little
bit better structural rigidity and you'd
be able to fit a bigger battery in there
just a thought Apple I said this in my
iPhone 6 impressions video and I said
before and I'm not the only one to say
it but I think a thicker phone would
have been a ok with a lot of people but
it seems the Internet has a thing for
bending stuff so I'll let you sit back
relax enjoy bent gate it's actually kind
of funny if you've read the stuff I'll
talk to you guys in the next video base